شخصيا في مدى عمقي
بالسيد المسيح ابانا دراسته في المرحله
الجامعيه وكان لدي شغف انذاك بدستوري
الولايات المتحده وكافه حياتي عندما كنت
شابا كانت بكل بساطه حياه بسيطه كنت
مسيحييا محافظا وجمهوريا وهذه الخطوات هي
التي اتشرف بانها كانت خصالا مني
وخدمه العامه تعود الى سنوات طويله فانا
كنت عضوا في الكونجرسواز
عن المحافظين كنت قد عملت مع حزبي على
تطبيق
كافه المبادئ الاساسيه
وقمنا بوضع اللوائح التنظيميه التي نظمت
طريقه التوظيف وطرق اختياري المرشحين
للوظائف في الولايات المتحده وكنائبا
للرئيس كنت اشعر بالفخر
لمهمه مع الرئيس ترامب في اربعه سنوات
تاريخيه حققنا من خلالها انجازات عظيمه
وكل شيء قد
حققته فيعزل فضل بذلك لاسرتي
وهذا بلعلني التقيته من وصفه الملك ديفيد
الذي كان يركز على اهميه الاسره اعتقد بحق
كل مواطن امريكي ليتمتع
بالحلم الامريكي
جبت البلاد لمده سنتين في سنتين الماضيين
الماضيتين وكنت قد رايت الفوارق التي
يعيشها المواطن الامريكي
التفاؤل الذي كان يسود في تلك السنوات قبل
قبل جائحه كوفي 19
وتغيرت لتصبح قلقا وخوفا من المستقبل
فهناك حاله من المخاوف لدى المواطنين
الامريكيين
هذه البلاد تعيش جمله من المشاكل الرئيس
جو بايدن
والديمقراطيون المتطرفون الذين كانوا قد
اثروا على امريكا بالداخل وبالخارج فكانت
بلادنا تحظى بمكانه رفيعه بكل تاكيد قبل
تلك الازمات لقد تسببنا بجمله من الازمه 5
ملايين شخص يقومون بعبور الحدود في
الولايات المتحده
هذا قد جر معه ازمه انسانيه متتاليه
في كافه ارجاء البلاد سياسه الاداره على
مر السنوات
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات